probablemente saben que si conectan una
batería con voltaje ve a un resistor con
resistencia r tendremos cierta cantidad
de corriente y podremos determinar
cuánta cantidad de corriente fluye por
acá usando la ley de ohm recuerden que
la ley de ohm dice que el voltaje que
pasa por un resistor es igual a la
corriente que pasa por ese resistor
multiplicado por la resistencia de ese
resistor y eso nos da una forma de
definir la resistencia de la resistencia
de este resistor está definida por la
cantidad de voltaje que se aplica a
través de esta dividida entre la
cantidad de corriente que fluye por el
resistor y esta es la definición de
resistencia y recuerden que esos
unidades son los oms pero tengan cuidado
de no caer en la trampa de pensar como
lo hacen muchas personas que para
aumentar la resistencia tienen que
incrementar el voltaje ya que esto me va
a dar un número más grande aquí arriba
la resistencia no funciona así si
incrementamos el voltaje también vamos a
incrementar la corriente y esta
proporción se va a mantener igual la
resistencia es una constante si no
estamos cambiando el material del que
está hecho este resistor o el tamaño o
la dimensión de este resistor el número
que es esta resistencia va a ser
constante si es que esto es realmente un
material único los materiales o micos
mantienen la misma resistencia sin
importar cual voltaje o corriente pase a
través de ellos y bueno si ponemos
demasiado voltaje o demasiada corriente
vamos a quemar al resistor lo que no les
aconsejo que hagan aquí tenemos un rango
de operación y si nos mantenemos dentro
de ese rango esta resistencia esta
cantidad de homs será constante sin
importar cuánto voltaje o cuánta
corriente tengamos aquí la resistencia
se define en términos del voltaje y la
corriente pero no
depende de ellos si queremos cambiar la
proporción el número que tiene esta
resistencia tendremos que cambiar algo
del propio resistor su tamaño el
material del que está hecho su longitud
su forma imaginemos cómo podríamos hacer
esto si tomamos este resistor lo
llevamos al taller cómo se va a ver
bueno para simplificar las cosas digamos
que tenemos un registro perfectamente
cilíndrico este es el cable que va en un
extremo este es nuestro resistor que
tiene forma cilíndrica y aquí está el
cable que sale del otro lado una cosa de
la que depende el resistor es de su
longitud lo que nos puede afectar la
resistencia otra cosa que nos puede
afectar la resistencia es el área del
resistor el área transversal de aquí es
el área transversal porque es hacia
dónde se dirige la corriente cuando
entra en el resistor esta corriente se
dirige hacia esta área
como si fuera un túnel iba a salir por
este otro lado esto no está hueco está
hecho de un material puede ser un metal
o algún compuesto del carbono o algún
semiconductor pero esto es algo sólido
la corriente pasa por aquí y sale por
acá
qué pasa si hacemos este resistor más
largo vamos a cambiar algunas de estas
variables y digamos que vamos a hacer
más grande esta longitud bueno ahora
esta corriente tendrá que pasar por un
lugar mucho más largo tendrá que pasar
por este resistor una distancia mayor y
a mí me parece lógico pensar que la
resistencia va a aumentar si
incrementamos la longitud de este
resistor la resistencia va a aumentar y
qué pasa si modificó el área transversal
si tengo aquí un cilindro con un
diámetro mayor bueno pues a mí me parece
lógico que ahora la corriente va a tener
más espacio por donde pasar hay un área
mayor en la cual la corriente puede
pasar
está tan restringida por lo que la
resistencia va a disminuir si ponemos
esto en una fórmula matemática nos va a
decir que si la resistencia depende de
la longitud va a ser directamente
proporcional a la longitud si duplicó la
longitud del resistor mi resistencia
también se va a duplicar pero con el
área si yo aumento el área voy a
disminuir la resistencia ya que la
corriente tendrá más espacio para pasar
por lo que en esta fórmula mi área tiene
que ir aquí abajo la resistencia de un
resistor es inversamente proporcional a
esta área transversal pero hay otra
cantidad de la cual depende esta
resistencia y esto es el material del
cual está hecho el resistor la geometría
determina la resistencia de igual manera
el material del que está hecho el
resistor algunos materiales
naturalmente ofrecen una mayor
resistencia a la corriente otros
materiales no tanto algunos metales
ofrecen muy poca resistencia a la
corriente y normalmente los
tales ofrecen más resistencia a la
corriente por lo que tenemos que
cuantificar la resistencia natural del
material del registro y a esto se le
llama la resistividad y se representa
con la letra griega rojo mientras más
grande sea la resistividad de un
material se resistirá más al paso de la
corriente naturalmente para darnos una
idea de los números aquí imaginemos que
tenemos la resistividad del cobre este
es un metal así que su resistencia va a
ser pequeña es 1.6 8 por 10 a la menos 8
en un momento vamos a hablar de las
unidades pero la resistividad de algo
como un plástico o un aislante va a ser
enorme estará en el orden de 10 a la 13
por lo que hay un rango enorme de
posibles valores de resistividad vamos
desde un metal conductor hasta un
semiconductor hasta un aislante ese es
el rango de resistividad y este es el
último valor que necesitamos para
nuestra fórmula la resistividad va aquí
mientras mayor sea la resiste
mayor será la resistencia lo cual tiene
sentido y también va a depender de estos
factores geométricos la longitud y el
área esta es la fórmula de todos los
factores que nos pueden cambiar la
resistencia en un resistor la
resistividad la longitud y el área
cuales son las unidades de la
resistividad puedo reacomodar esta
fórmula y me queda que la resistividad
es igual a la resistencia multiplicada
por el área dividida entre la longitud y
esto me da las unidades de homs por
metro al cuadrado / metro metro al
cuadrado es el área dividido entre la
longitud por lo que me quedan oms uno de
estos metros se cancelan y me queda ohms
por metro estas son las unidades de la
resistividad o por metros y bueno como
podremos recordar esta fórmula tenemos
el área abajo la longitud de arriba y yo
espero que ustedes recuerden de donde
salieron estos factores pero a veces es
un poco difícil de recordar esta fórmula
y uno de mis estudiantes de periodos
anteriores
ocurrió que esto se parecía a la palabra
inventada regla está r pues es una r
este signo de igual parece una e la ro
parece una p
y bueno la l sigue siendo una l y la una
por lo que nos queda regla y cada que
veo esta fórmula me recuerda a esta
palabra inventada replà y éste me mónico
me gusta si me ayuda a recordar esta
fórmula y ya que estamos hablando de la
resistividad tiene sentido que hablemos
de la conductividad la conductividad
eléctrica la resistividad nos da una
idea de que tanto un material
naturalmente se resiste al paso de la
corriente la conductividad nos dice que
tanto algo naturalmente
permite el paso de la corriente y esto
es inversamente proporcional a la
resistividad y realmente esto es muy
sencillo la resistividad es igual a 1
entre la conductividad eléctrica el
símbolo que usamos para la conductividad
eléctrica es
esta letra griega sigma es la
conductividad eléctrica y ro
la resistividad es 1 / sigma el inverso
de la conductividad y viceversa sigma es
igual a 1 entre la resistividad ya que
si algo es un buen resistor va a ser un
mal conductor y si algo es un gran
conductor será un mal resistor estas
cosas son inversamente proporcionales y
si tenemos el valor de una ya conocemos
la otra y si esto les parece un poco
abstracto tenemos una buena analogía que
podemos hacer con el agua vimos que un
resistor depende de unas cosas como la
resistividad mientras más grande sea la
resistividad mayor será la resistencia
vimos que mientras más grande sea la
longitud del resistor mayor será la
resistencia y si lo dividimos entre el
área del resistor veremos que la
resistencia es inversamente proporcional
al área del resistor hagamos una
analogía con el agua
imaginemos que en lugar de tener
electrones que pasan por aquí fluyendo
por un alambre imaginemos que tenemos
una tubería un tubo por el cual el agua
puede pasar así que en lugar de
electrones aquí tenemos agua diferentes
tuberías tendrán diferente
resistencia al paso del agua que podría
afectarlo imaginen que tenemos una
constricción en esta tubería si está
construida va a ser más difícil para el
agua pasar por aquí por lo que va a
tener una resistencia al paso del agua
el agua ya no va a fluir tan fácilmente
por acá debido a esta construcción y de
qué depende esta construcción pues
mientras más pequeña sea esta área
reducida la resistencia será mayor y
esto coincide con lo que tenemos aquí
arriba si tenemos un área pequeña aquí y
dividimos entre un número pequeño
nuestro resultado será mayor por lo que
tendremos una resistencia mayor eso
tiene sentido y también depende de la
longitud si aumentamos la longitud de
esta construcción para el agua será más
difícil
fluir hay manuales para plomeros en
donde verán que hay una clave para
determinar dependiendo de la longitud de
una tubería cuando a presión se
necesitará acá mientras más pequeña sea
la construcción en términos de su área y
su longitud mientras más larga sea vamos
a necesitar mayor presión aquí
imaginemos que en la analogía la presión
es similar a la fuente a la fuente de
corriente a nuestra batería así que en
lugar de tener una batería que nos
proporciona el voltaje en este circuito
tendremos algo que genera presión para
hacer que el agua fluya de la misma
forma que lo tenemos en la batería en
donde lo que importa es la diferencia de
voltaje lo que importa con la presión de
aquí es el cambio en la presión entre un
punto del sistema y otro punto de este
esto tiene sentido mientras mayor sea la
longitud de la constricción mayor será
la resistencia mientras más pequeña sea
el área también la resistencia será
mayor ya que sería análoga nuestra
resistividad pues esto sería análogo al
material
del cual está hecha la tubería si esta
tubería tiene una superficie interna
rugosa el agua no va a fluir tan
fácilmente por ahí sí tenemos una
superficie suave el agua va a fluir más
fácilmente y esto va a suceder sin
importar qué tan larga sea la
construcción o qué área tenga la
naturaleza del material de la tubería
por sí sola va a determinar qué tan
fácil o qué tan difícil es para la
corriente pasar por ahí de la misma
forma que nuestra resistividad en el
resistor la resistividad depende del
material del que está hecho el resistor
y la resistividad de la tubería depende
del material de las paredes interiores
yo espero que es tecnología les ayude a
comprender mejor esta fórmula pero en
caso de que no sea así vamos a hacer un
ejemplo vamos a quitar todo esto y
digamos que tenemos este problema cuánta
resistencia tendrá un alambre de cobre
de 12 metros con un diámetro de 0.01
metros el cobre tiene una resistencia
de 1.68 por 10 a la menos 8 qué unidades
tiene esta resistividad resulta que la
resistividad tiene unidades de homs por
metro
vamos a usar nuestra fórmula nuestro n
mónico es rep la r igual a row l sobre a
la resistividad la tenemos aquí 1.68 por
10 a la menos 8 y noten que esto es algo
muy pequeño el cobre es un muy buen
conductor y también es un terrible
resistor permite pasar a los electrones
como si nada la longitud es muy fácil es
de 12 metros noten que nos están
preguntando cuál es la resistencia del
alambre en sí mismo aquí no tenemos
entre comillas un registro pero
cualquier alambre va a ofrecer cierta
resistencia a la corriente y esta
fórmula aplica lo mismo para un pedazo
de alambre que para un resistor la
longitud de este alambre es de 12 metros
y el diámetro es de 0.01 que tenemos que
hacer con esto puedes encontrar el área
necesitamos él
transversal y el área de un círculo es
tipo radio al cuadrado el área aquí
abajo va a ser x 1.01 al cuadrado punto
01 es el diámetro
necesitamos el radio la mitad del
diámetro la mitad de esto es 0.005
metros al cuadrado y si calculamos todo
esto nos va a dar una resistencia de
0.00 26 ohms casi nada pero hay cierta
resistencia si esto va a usarse en un
experimento delicado tenemos que tomar
en cuenta este dato si tenemos un
alambre que es muy largo
mientras más largo sea el alambre mayor
será la resistencia que ofrezca y nos
puede afectar el sistema pero en el caso
del alambre de cobre éste permite pasar
a los electrones como si nada ya que su
resistencia es muy muy pequeña